if people have to treat you a certain
way for you to be happy then it means
that your happiness is in their hands I
get asked about mindset a lot on
podcasts they're like when you're
building a business or you're building a
career there are stressors that come
into play how we manage the
circumstances or the conditions that
come to us dictates how our life turns
out everybody has bad stuff happen you
probably believed and nodded your head
like yeah everyone has stuff happen and
then we choose to make it bad or good
imagine for a second two children that
are playing one child tells the other
child your nose is really big or you're
fat
interesting is that the child who hears
it is unaffected and the child who says
it is unaffected they're like you're fat
and he's like huh parent comes in and
overhears it and she's like oh my God
takes the child that was called fat
Comforts them gives them the expectation
that they should be upset and then tells
the other one that that was bad and in a
moment there was something that is now
traumatic that otherwise wouldn't have
been and so when we're kids we walk into
the world with no meaning all we do is
we we observe and then whatever the
adults around us tell us and say this
means that we take his fact and it's not
true it's their interpretation of the
world and we inherit them and then we
spend the rest of our life trying to
undo and examine these beliefs that we
have been told by people that we
probably don't agree with when something
bothers you pull it out and look at and
say what happened and why is this bad
and what would it look like if it were
good and so the two tools that I use are
time and volume the volume example is
thinking okay I'm in traffic if this
happened every day would I be upset if
it happened every day I'd probably
expect it which means that I would not
be upset about it because it's just how
things always are if you want to make it
positive you say well what if every time
I got in a car normally it would take an
hour and today it took 30. I'd be pretty
excited about it and so all we did is
just change the volume on the
circumstance to recalibrate the meaning
that we're choosing to ascribe to it
good or bad I like to think of
circumstances a lot like weather which
is like you've got sunny days and you've
got rainy days and the problem in my
opinion is that people any day that it
rains they say is bad and any day that's
Sunny they say is good when in reality
it just is it's just the weather
contrast is what create the quote good
and bad when really there's just a
middle line and half of it's above and
half of it's below then what we can do
is artificially move the line in our
minds by saying whatever this
circumstance is what would it look like
if it were worse and what would it look
like if it were worse all the time and
if so then maybe today's a good thing
the second frame that I like to use is
time a hundred years out but 10 000
years out how much is this going to
matter the reason something affects you
is because you have deemed it meaningful
you've said it matters it's my world
view that nothing matters with a capital
M like nothing matters in the universe
it doesn't matter there's this statue of
a head that's in the Sands of Egypt all
right and it's bigger than this whole
room it's just the head it's worn out
and then scripted along the forehead it
says here lies
crazy name who owned everything that the
eye could see the immortal so-and-so and
the only thing that was left was a worn
out statue head that no one knew who he
was and it was five thousand years old
if that guy who ruled the known world to
him wealth probably mattered right but
does it matter no probably not I've
relieved a lot of the pressure in my
life so that I could make better
decisions by zooming way out and
thinking ten thousand years from now
will this matter and if the answer is no
does it matter to me and then if I can
make the decision of like good or bad
based on my new context that I created
then I can live a life a lot easier and
so for me that helped me decrease
anxiety it helped me decrease sadness
around certain circumstances and I'll
give you the last example of this so I
had a cat named Bill Chill Bill rest in
peace homie Love the cat he died this is
some freak heart thing or something so
he died in like two years when he died I
was bumped I was like this sucks then I
thought to myself what if cats only
normally lived six months how stoked
would I be that he lived four times the
normal length of a normal cat I was like
I'd probably be really stuck I'd be like
dude he lived a long life I can't
believe we had him this long and all of
a sudden my perspective around the death
completely changed I was like I was so
grateful that I got to have him as long
as I did when you play with time and you
play with volume first off we have to be
aware of the levers of meaning that
exist and then once you're aware of them
you can start moving them in your favor
and then looking at your current
conditions through different lenses and
say what would this mean if it were
amazing what would the conditions have
to be in order for this to be an awesome
thing and then all of a sudden you just
exit the game of happy sad and get to be
your own own game maker at least that's
what I tried to do when I get upset look
at it pull it apart thing like is this
real is this true is anyone doing this
perfectly no but simply being aware of
the fact gives you a lot more control
over your own perception of life and the
conditions that are presented to you